our next guest originally wanted to be a
professional baseball player but had to
settle for a career in golf and he got
off to a slow start on the links he
didn't even win his first Masters he
came in second but he didn't give up on
the sport despite those early struggles
he finally won that tournament in his
second try becoming the second-youngest
Masters winner in history for all his
success on the course his favorite
football team the Dallas Cowboys haven't
won a Super Bowl since he was a baby
hopefully he can keep his head up this
week please welcome Jordan I gotta bring
football in it look at you wait wait
where's your back oh yeah yeah yeah
thank you very much
wait wait do you are you allowed to
carry your own bag not anymore do you
why yeah I know I have somebody
full-time for that now y know there's a
candy but are you do you ever pick up
your own golf bag oh yeah absolutely
okay yeah what's in there didn't feel
like I needed to right here I didn't
Paulie would you bring over no thank you
okay be careful it's the suitcase wave
cares there's two extra clubs for you
and extra what is in there that would
surprise me oh it would surprise you in
there probably all the chocolate that
Michael eats it's like he's got all
probably some melted M&Ms in his pocket
that have been there since like last
summer like I'll go in and grab a nickel
out of using nickel to mark my ball I'll
grab a nickel out and half of it'll be
covered in chocolate I'm like I'll be
like hey we'd call it heads or tails
brown food all the chocolate it's it's
aw he likes to snack out there so
there's an unlimited supply of snacks in
this bag Congrats Yuri up with AT&T yeah
I'm very excited yeah we did a
multi-year agreement 2014 yeah and then
just just re-upped now for another
multi-year agreement so I'm pumped it's
awesome have you been employee of the
month at AT&T I not that I know of
highly doubt it oh wow that's awkward
cuz I have oh yeah yeah boy it's nice to
I've certainly I've certainly done all I
can
to win that award but sir I guess not
enough well Tom Brady was never the
Patriot of the week well yeah I mean he
he would be every week right no he'd
never wanted but it was brought up like
that was an issue that he didn't get to
be patriot of the week I would think
winning you know a few Super Bowls you
would they would give you that parking
spot that says favorite Patriot right
less there unless that's his his way of
continuing to be the underdog motivated
right yeah we're not buying into that
underdog yeah they are and it's working
yeah I know how painful is it to watch
though being a Cowboy fan did you watch
the Super Bowl yeah it wasn't painful
being a Cowboys fan it just
unfortunately there wasn't a ton of
action in the game but there were a lot
of great plays made I mean defensive
schemes were unbelievable I mean the
most upset person at the end of that
Super Bowl had to be Wade Phillips I
mean he did he held the Patriots to one
snap in the red zone the entire game
yeah and and I mean he did his job you
know the same with the defense it's just
uh how would you do in the booth um for
a football game yeah not well I mean
I've learned the majority of my football
from really just kind of listening to
Tony this year tell me about how
defenses work and adjust and whatnot so
how would Romo do as a broadcaster and
goal I think he'd do well I think he'd
do really well he's I think he likes
golf more than football but but how
could he predict because he already
knows yeah the predictions you don't be
so accurate but because in golf I mean
they that announcers curse doesn't
really have necessarily the same effect
it's like I mean the guy's probably not
gonna make the 20-footer the chances
were 20% you know it's like I got this
feeling he's gonna make this one and do
you hear the announcer when like you'll
have when they they put the program or
they put something down whispers so you
you can hear them on the course
sometimes you'll hear the you'll hear
the radio guys that are behind the green
they hold their clipboard up yeah
talking and normally I don't hear it
when it's me putting but I can hear it
when somebody else is like I'm closer to
where that person and you just it's you
don't really want to hear it you just
you never know it like they never know
what they're saying you just kind of
want to be focused on the pot or the the
shot or whatever it is but they do a
good job staying away if you could
listen to music while you played yeah go
do I do at home a lot okay and what do
you listen I've really I put on a
variety like I'll do what would surprise
me um what would surprise you I
sometimes I'm on like a classic rock
kick okay and I'll just go to I use
Spotify mainly and I just I'll go to one
of the radio stations of a banner
musician that I can and just play music
similar to that okay but what would
surprise me like Britney Spears you're
like no I don't think Celine Dion I
don't think I've listened to Celine Dion
in a while either okay but I'll be it'll
be like 40 degrees and blowing 20 in
Dallas and I'll have like Kenny Chesney
radio and thinking I'm on a beach okay
you know sometimes and that'll relax me
a little bit and no shoes no shirt no
problem there's not yeah exactly there's
no problem yeah last concert you went to
I went last concert I went to probably
been a little while now I went to Easton
Corbin actually it's yeah a week and a
half ago hasn't been a while I was at
Billy Bob's in Fort Worth yeah went to
the Fort Worth rodeo and then went over
and he was playing at Billy Bob's and
which is a concert venue their popular
old dance hall and Fort Worth I saw him
was he good you get recognized no we
kind of snuck in and went down sat in
the back and now I didn't there I ever
worn on this guy's yeah yeah I've won a
mustache before not can't grow one
no I yeah I I've tried it okay doesn't
you know like Ricky Ricky's got his
mustache and it's it's questionable it
is no it's bit and mines mines another
level of bad so you've got a fake
mustache I had yeah I had a fake
mustache yeah it was kind of a joke I
think I got I got it like a some props
at somebody's wedding that props and I
just kept it and I put it on here yeah
it worked
why not what are you put down on your
time
for job uh-huh I put down either I put
the I put down self-employed okay yeah
nothing like yeah in parentheses
anything like now I'm down golfer have
you ever had an on golfing job no why
said Raghav a pull I heard a wire no no
delivering pizzas like Burger King
McDonald's drive-through none of that
you know I I haven't I feel spoiled in
saying so but from I my dad told me
later he said you know I showed a lot of
promise when I was younger in golf and
to him it was if this is your goal and
you're gonna work at it then if you're
going to continue to do so and get a
scholarship through golf then you don't
have to go get a job and that was kind
of the deal okay so you went to a
baseball game with your dad when you
were younger
oh yeah didn't we we missed a foul pop
yeah I that's how my two front teeth got
knocked out yeah I was at a we used to
go to a lot of Ranger games growing up
when they were really bad so you could
buy you know the cheap tickets and then
you could walk all the way down and I
think it was my uncle actually that was
there with us through it
there's area to play catch in the back
all the kids would go and we bring our
gloves and got caught in the light
looking up jam just they weren't ready
to come out either it was a mess they
didn't come back in for a long time but
you're a good baseball player weren't
you yeah but I mean there's no not much
you could do and the lights are bright
as the ones on you and here right now I
mean there's just a ball gets yeah yeah
yeah you guys think this is easy
yeah I mean anybody can play augusto but
I'm talking to these bright lights right
here that's right yeah what you can't
even see in here could you host this
show absolutely not
you couldn't not know why because I have
no practice in doing so no you got those
guys they're the dentist doesn't make it
easier does it
no no but do you think you have to be a
good listener and you you have to be
curious about a lot of things okay yeah
are you a good listener not really yeah
but you're married yeah that's that's a
that's gonna be a problem point is no
you've gotta be a good listener you got
it are you curious yes then think I'm
curious and I'm a and I'm a sports geek
okay what would you ask me what was your
what was your take on the Super Bowl I
were you disappointed or or do you have
a different viewpoint I was hoping that
we would see both teams play up to what
they were supposed to her we hoped they
would be because it's two weeks in
between the conference title games in
the Super Bowl and there was a long time
where it never lived up to the billing
and I was hoping it would just the Rams
would be able to play as well as they do
in the Patriots would as well and then
whoever won but unfortunately it was a
boring game and you know the first three
quarters then you got a little bit of
drama I mean if you said look scores
tied going in the fourth quarter
everybody would sign up except for it
was three three growing into the fourth
quarter
right did you like maroon 5 I I do I do
enjoy their music the halftime show was
interesting I I didn't like like I had
nothing against maroon 5 but I just I
didn't know what they were doing
yeah I think they had to play around so
much with like you don't normally see
I don't normally watch concerts but you
don't normally see a concert where the
cameras just right up squared up like
they're not really sure I wouldn't know
what to do they're either like deep I
probably wouldn't have taken my shirt
off but like do you do you dance are you
singing like if you just sing you're
just kind of standing still I just I
would I went the only Super Bowl I've
ever been to was the was the one in
Phoenix where Seattle through it instead
of running it in the Patriots one I
think it was it was in 16 no in 15 the
14 season I'm pretty sure and that one
was the one where you had the sharks and
Katy Perry at halftime
yeah and being there watching that was
actually an amazing performers
but it was it was wacky but it was fun
yeah yeah and she like came in from the
top and had this green is it was but
that was entertaining this one you know
I mean in and this is that's the one
game where you're sitting around you
want to see the commercials you know
want to see the halftime show and
honestly I could have just taken my
bathroom break or food break during the
game to be honest but but hey I mean the
scheming that Belichick did was
phenomenal and then you know Tom throws
it just an unbelievable ball and a
triple coverage to Gronk and that's
that's what they needed I mean it was
look at you breaking it down it was uh
have you met oh yeah I'm a big TV 12 in
oh yeah big Tom fan you play golf with
him I have I've actually played a gussto
with him before well it was a neat
experience yeah I buried the lead there
could have come in and I'm in hot I
could have yeah I was trying to trying
to stay trying to stay back a little on
my yeah it was great how many shots did
you give it we had a two on two match
and I ended up burning the 18th he had a
stroke on the 18th I hit it in there too
few feet and he he he drove it up close
almost too close to the green and tried
to hit a flop shot left in the bunker
made bogey the match was tied so I won
he made bogey I made birdie for a
two-shot flip on the last and you're
supposed to go in at Augusta and you
know have lunch and and hang out and he
didn't say a word to me for like an hour
and a half I mean the most competitive I
feel like I'm very very competitive and
he is the most competitive human being
I've ever met
it's it's this is like this is like a
fun round does he understand that he
gets in that moment and then he can't
get out I don't I don't think he wants
to think he likes that I mean but don't
you want to joke with him and say hey 12
it was when they started making their
comeback on the back nine he was
talkative oh yeah yeah but but I would
me and that's when I'd go for the kill I
did think when I hit the three footer I
was looking at him is one of those I
think that's probably didn't help at the
cause of him
winning twos I would have said this is
my dojo Tom like welcome in yeah yeah
I'm mr. Miyagi Yeah right yeah
the annual Sun a football boy take this
what's the strangest thing you ever
thought of when you're over the ball
putt like maybe it's like a what's that
smell you know I like Michael maybe had
some rough go blue downwind it's like
that probably be the weirdest thing
where you're over it and you're you're
just all the sudden you're just like
wait a second
but is he trying to is he laughing when
this happened no I
I mean that would have been that's
somewhat hypothetical okay somewhat he
or it's you know or it's somebody or you
know sometimes here in California we
played in Colorado you catch a little
whiff of something in the air oh and
when you're over the ball so a little
second it's close and if it doesn't
relax you then at least is something
that's over the ball if you go to your
bag and you grab Doritos out of there
maybe maybe you're affected maybe it was
Michael that's where all these snacks in
here oh oh I was in Seattle how's the
game yeah good trending I'm trending
trending what does that mean I like that
word it's means it's moving the right
direction okay yeah it means results are
coming not forcing him into it just like
I had a like an off year last year and
then starting to I had some time to work
on some things and now I've got a good
stretch of three weeks in a row starting
here
I've played well here historically so
ideally continue that and then you know
everything revolves around trying to
peak for the the Masters first the four
majors so I'm waiting to run into a
golfer when I say how's your game and
they go I'm unbelievably horrible I hate
this game I want to quit talk to a
non-professional that's what most
everybody will say have you ever had one
of those moments where you go I I forgot
how to play or I have nightmare yeah
yeah I mean certainly I've lost sleep
over stuff I'm working on I can't figure
it out at different times different
periods of time I think
anybody in their job when they're just
going through something where it's their
job becomes harder to them than it than
it was at some point then you're just
you're trying to just get back on the
right track and your own worst enemy
yeah a hundred percent yeah especially
in golf it's I mean if you're not
thinking about the right things or being
focused over the ball then you're you're
in some trouble
yeah the last thing you want to do is
think yeah right yeah ideally ideally
you've put all the pieces in place it's
just reactive if you actually make golf
athletic if you're not thinking you guys
react to the shot that's needed it's
great to see it during me a commercial
break will you give a tip the one tip
that you would give to every amateur
absolutely okay all right and no one
will ever ask you for that one tip and
all the programs that you play you just
I I will shout I will send the video to
you just pull out your phone and just
say watch this perfect I told everybody
on the Dan Patrick show perfect we'll
continue with jordan Spieth on the live
look in if you're watching on audience
you know 239 Direct TV the NBC Sports
Network the one tip that Jordan speith
tells every amateur to make them good
average just a tip okay wow that's great
tune in factor okay I don't know if it
was worth waiting get you through the
commercial break but Jordan promised
that he would give a tip I don't know if
it's a good tip or not but this is the
one thing every amateur should know or
ask you about they need to hit more club
into greens so what will happen what I
see a lot is somebody will hit a 7-iron
on the range and it'll go 180 yards and
they just assume they're gonna hit the
7-iron 180 yards every time they hit it
and go get on the course they'll have
180 yards and they pull a 7-iron and
they come up short of the green they're
wondering because your contacts not as
consistent as say ours is therefore when
you miss hit it off the heel-toe thin
fat whatever it is I mean knocks 10 to
15 yards off the ball so if you just hit
more clubs swing a little easier you
probably have a better chance of better
contact I've never seen an ammeter flush
one out of pin and go
the green in my life I've never seen it
happen unless it were a jumper is always
short always short or or good I mean
short or good you know you're never
gonna see any one of these for amateurs
flush went over this well there you go
and so the other thing is this so for us
whenever you see us working on the range
we're almost always working on the same
thing or something in your basics have
gotten off something in your setup
posture ball position alignment if you
have those checked down typically we
start to figure out the rest of its
hanged up with your hands yeah they're
pretty banged up it's golf yeah yeah
I've been like I said I've been trying
to trend the right here and if I if I
said pick the sport that that hand is
involved in yeah this is kind of this
got cut open in here some somehow what
there's some grip pressure issues here
aren't I I know it's I got kind of a
little bit of a weird grip and it just
makes these calluses and if I got rid of
the calluses they would just blister up
I think there's offensive lineman in the
NFL who instead of it being cows as
their knuckles are normally well if you
were picking the golfer out of this
group just based on looks if this is a
program and you get you get to pick
based on looks
McLovin ollie
Seaton was just hitting balls I think
he's we should probably he should
probably continue to hit him he had a
little warm-up oh so he would be your
guy yeah no not based on necessarily
your original that that would be the
wise choice Seaton would be the guy on
your team I don't know because yeah it's
not that he's any good it's this these
guys aren't at all he wouldn't select me
oh my god no no no I don't know I feel
like Andrews done well so far while
we're here Paulie hits it straight every
time short and straight yeah well now
here's pressure all right before I let
Jordan go win a tournament cameras on
you
Jordan's gonna just watch this this the
approach shot on 18 at Pebble ooh you
got to get up ready just put one up on
the green radius up there's no you got
water on the left on 18 at Pebble I know
I want you to I want you to broadcast
this no so what do you okay ice will get
there I think you flew the green season
I think you did that's that's that's
it's 8 feet below the hole that's it's
still a poor lot for me though on one of
them that's good yeah thanks bud
absolutely yeah thank you
of course my swings a little steep but
it's also it's also wet turf you know is
that what it is right it yeah no no and
we're good you guys hit any of those up
there here we did but not not very often
and we did it off the air but it's the
thing about 6:30 we were you can listen
yeah it's good action though straight
yeah straight yeah I got a most
important everyone wants to hit it
further it's like I just want to hit it
straighter I do right which is yep
moving or steep yeah that one
oh it is it's two down okay - too choppy
yeah
but they want to chop it when it's so
wet like I'm doing the same thing here
on the course it's like when the grass
is this kind of spongy you feel like
you're gonna hit it fat so you just try
and hit even more down on it and it
doesn't make it any better
but you're trying to compress it even
more I'm trying you're almost trying to
shallow it out like come in okay off
this type of grass it's easier when it's
really like no one wants to hit it fat
when it's wet out and you feel like it's
you have a better chance of hitting a
fat so you go steeper versus if you have
if if the club can just get down
just stay right here and be shallower
it's actually easier to strike it better
one of the one wants to do it's like the
opposite of what you feel like doing but
but also the weird thing when you tell
people swinging you want to swing
through like people swing down the line
yeah but aren't you guys changing your
swing angles now doesn't it feel like
it's more like I yeah see guys who are
practicing to get you know through here
like instead of going down the line
right I think it depends on what shot
you're trying to hit but your we're
always hips are clearing before you even
strike it and everything just kind of
follows along whatever you can use your
big muscles on you don't want to use
your hands as much hands just kind of
either hold to work the ball to the
right or close a little bit like you
were talking about to hit a draw but can
you get more power yeah didn't you get
more power
I would load more into this side so I
would I would create this angle of my
back when I take it back instead of
being here I would make it here and then
I have more force that goes into it
but I mean that's something we're always
trying to work on with me but you see
not for powers but like champ gets out
here and you mean when he caught recoils
he's like here like he's got all this
force he's so effective and efficient in
his swing he also hits down on it which
is unusual if he hit up on it he hit it
further oh my god but it but he wouldn't
have the same control for him just
because that's the way he swings Faldo
said last year that he thought that we
had kind of topped out on how far you
can hit the golf ball with equipment yes
but like everybody can get more
efficient a little bit more efficient
but would you swing differently if you
were coming up now if you if it was 10
years 15 you know probably not if
anything I would have added a little bit
more of that into it but I still try to
all the time it's really hard to do when
you have this kind of because because if
I were to do it with like this 9-iron
and I tried to hit it really far
likelihood is I would hit it fat right
now just because I'm not used to being
that far back and underneath yeah but it
would take me after I hit one fat the
next one wouldn't be and I did
further well but like I wouldn't trust
that on the course how do you explain
Bubba to someone who doesn't know golf
as a golfer his swing yeah I wouldn't
say this person he's I love I love the
way that he plays because he's
essentially just being an artist it's
all feel it's all feel he's an artist
and he'll work whatever he wants for
whatever the whole entails I love that
like I'm jealous of that like it so the
angle though it's it's bizarre who can
he can't no no it's bizarre that he's
able to step up and hit a driver that
curves 25 yards right to left and then
the next shot he can hit a 7-iron the
curves that much right right to left or
left to right and be that like effective
and be able to do it to that and degree
like for us it's so much easier if we
work if you just tell me hey I'm gonna
hit a 10 yard draw a hundred times in a
row and then just hit a fade I just
barely have to adjust like he's doing
massive adjustments on every shot yeah
and it's working well for him he's able
to do them it's bizarre well the shot at
Augusta yeah the hook yeah yeah you're
just going who does that yeah I mean
that one that's uh it's a good example
it's like we can all hit that shot if it
were flipped around and right-hander to
hit a hook with yeah edge there yeah but
like he's used to playing that shot so
he knows how much exactly to hook it
when we have to hook a pitching wedge or
whatever he hit a 9-iron that much it's
like I mean I maybe do that once a week
when a trees in my way and I have to but
under pressure to do it to at Augusta
and you're going yeah sure I'll just
just flip it over yeah yeah manipulate
here exactly it's it's it's special he's
got it he's got unbelievable hands do
you hate talking golf no no if I see you
like go on it you could talk anything
yeah I'd talk other sports okay yeah cuz
I wonder cuz I always get that people go
oh you know I've strayed and how worried
I was
yeah I mean that's Don chicken looks
great
I think Hardaway jr. is underrated it
could grab two yeah
Luke has been awesome yes yeah but for
Zynga's better be healthy because yeah i
think i mean you guys would know better
you but he is healthier good play but
he's just been overprotective yeah which
is well I don't think he's wanted to
play for the next man I think that was
part of it but you know I give Cuban
credit he he's been asking about
porzingis for a couple of years he
wanted him and then i think we you know
he realized what he had with dhansak so
now you got I got Nowitzki and Nash kind
of recreated here yeah yeah and I think
it's you know he took a chance and the
Knicks always screw things up so even if
they've got draft picks and all of that
though would you rather the Cowboys
wanted the Mavs one I'd rather have a
Super Bowl I was I was a senior in high
school in the Mavs won the championship
so I've got one reason like that was
prime like that's a perfect time to win
a championship is he like a senior in
high school
do you imagine if your kid in
Massachusetts and let's say you're 15
have you seen the kid that goes around
with the banner and and he there's a kid
he's got one he was like he got all the
champion years eight banners and then
the same and then you see these pictures
side by side there's like six of them or
whatever yeah it's like 16 years old he
doesn't know they don't lose you know in
a two year span I mean you know it's a
slump like we're never gonna win again
I imagine growing up like that alright
well I know you got stuff to to do here
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]